der april ist der garten an schlechthin
weil alles was man jetzt macht sich auf
die komplette gartensaison auswirken
wird und der schäden zeige ich euch
heute welche gartenarbeiten im april
richtig richtig sind
einige gemüse wollen ja im haus
vorgezogen werden und da habt ihr
bestimmt schon einige pflänzchen dadurch
an der fensterbank ausgesät in kleine
töpfchen oder unter den anzug lichtern
die jetzt bald nach draußen gepflanzt
werden wollen und deswegen ist es ganz
wichtig dass er die jetzt fertig damit
die kein sonnenbrand bekommen wenn du
steht wandern deswegen stellt die man
tagsüber ein bisschen nach draußen nicht
live in die pralle sonne dass sie sich
nach und nach draußen gewöhnen können
und auch an ihn sind und dann die
kühleren temperaturen und da gebe ich
meinen pflanzen immer somit für eine
woche zeit wo ich sie nach und nach an
draußen gewinne bevor sie dann wirklich
nach draußen ins beet wandern ja und im
frühling fällt nicht nur das gemüse an
ganz toll zu wachsen sondern ja auch die
unkräuter und wenn ihr und weiteren
bieten habt dann denk dran das ist
richtig sinnvoll ist wenn man die ecke
zu langsam sind weil das dann viel
weniger arbeit macht also immer
hinterher bleiben quer zum glück relativ
unkrautfrei gebete beziehungsweise
auslösen zahl wächst da eigentlich kaum
was und das ist super praktisch wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie das funktioniert
endfällige ich euch mal unter dem video
einen mini kurs den ich gefilmt habe da
könnt ihr gerne mal reinschauen und
schauen die stubete so anlegen dass
möglichst unkrautfrei bleiben aber wenn
wir euch unkraut wächst dann bleibt auf
jeden fall am ball jetzt ist es gerade
bei uns hier total warm und angenehm
auch nachts aber bis mitte mai kann ja
immer noch größte drohen deswegen denkt
daran den wetterbericht im auge zu
behalten und packt eure pflänzchen im
zweifel lieber noch keinen winterschutz
fliesst ein das murmeltier ein aber
lässt weiter licht und wasser durch und
das ist total sinnvoll um erstens die
ernte zu verfrüht und zweitens ist die
gemüsepflanzen im frühling und auch im
winter ein bisschen zu beschützen bewegt
denn thema beschützen und einkommen sind
kohlgemüse und auch der lauf werden von
so vielen schädlingen angeknabbert und
befallen dass sich die immer unter
seinem gemüse kultur schützen ex anbau
das heißt bevor er die jetzt wieder
richtig anfangen los zu leben und eure
pflanzen befallen sind auf jeden fall
über den col also gerade weißkohl
rotkohl will sind soweit alle kurse nyse
und auch den lauch einfachen schutznetz
drüber machen und dann sind die pflanzen
sich darauf eine sehr natürlich die art
und weise ihr müsst nicht spritzen ihr
müsst nicht absammeln wahrscheinlich
kennt ihr das wenn ihr das mich macht
das der kohl im sommer sonst voll ist
von kleinen raupen und das ist ziemlich
nervig und beim nächsten punkt gibt es
auch uns beschützen denkt daran dass ihr
auch eure jungen pflänzchen vor
schnecken schützt die werden jetzt
wieder richtig aktiv manchmal gehe ich
nach solchen garten und sammeln dann
ganz einmal verlass das ist wirklich
fies deswegen entweder schnitten kragen
darüber machen oder regelmäßig ab
sammeln können die schnecken tragen auch
gut selber basteln habe ich mein video
darüber gemacht daß verlinkt ich euch
gerne mal da oben in der ecke oder auch
unten in der video beschreibung jetzt
ist es auch an der zeit sich um die
sommer himbeeren zu kümmern also wenn
ihr hirn werden habt und die haben ihre
früchte immer im sommer gibt der sommer
und herbst hin werden über die sommer
gehen wären dann lichtet mal die neuen
triebe die da aus der erde kommen so aus
dass nur gefällt sehen triebe chor
laufenden meter noch übrig bleiben und
dann werdet ihr eine hübsche schöne
dicke der ernte haben und der nächste
punkt da geht es auch ums schneiden ihr
habt jetzt noch chancen der wende zu
schneiden darüber habe ich auch schon
mal ein video gemacht das finde ich auch
gerne darum also denkt weil das ist
einer sind wirklich sehr wichtig beim
nächsten tipp geht es um erdbeeren und
zwar nicht irgendwelche sondern die
coolsten erdbeeren nämlich die monats
erdbeeren das sind die die das ganze
jahr über früchte trage also nicht nicht
im winter aber die kämpfe ihr habt der
saison über immer wieder früchte bilden
die anderen erdbeeren die bilden einmal
eine größere ernte und dann ist es auch
wieder vorbei etwas besser zum
haltbarmachen wenn man etwa marmelade
machen natürlich praktisch einmal ganz
viel zu haben aber wenn ihr etwas zum
naschen an bord dann denkt daran dass
jetzt richtig toller zeitpunkt ist um
noch ein paar monaten irgendwo mit den
ski zu klassen aber eigentlich nur 1
euro ich denke auch an die ganzen tollen
insekten die beim wert dann ja auch
super wichtig sind und legt vielleicht
auch ein blühstreifen an wenn wir
irgendwo in einer gartenecke noch ein
bisschen klatsch sich das kann man jetzt
auch wunderbar machen es auch tolle
auszeit mischungen so dass man sich da
gar nicht so viele gedanken darüber
machen wo es ist einfacher für euch sind
vertun aber natürlich auch die ganzen
tierchen die da kreucht und fleucht
jetzt wo alles wärmer wird und richtig
wächst braucht natürlich die gemüse auch
ein bisschen was zu essen und die
schwinge ich den hunger vor allem die
stadt sicher das werden die gemüse die
richtig viel dünger brauchen deswegen
fange ich jetzt auch an könnte ihm zu
sammeln und andere pflanzen und daraus
herzustellen sobald die auch anfangen zu
wachsen so dass man wieder noch parat
als ansonsten denke ich auch die starke
serie ist langsam mal mit einem
flüssigdünger über das gießwasser mir
ist es immer total wichtig dass ich
biologischem dünger verwendet und keine
chemischen da gibt es auch super tolle
dinger die genauso toll wirken also
denkt an das gerade sowie kohlgemüse die
jetzt schon im bett stehen auch ein
bisschen was brauchen damit sie schön
groß entdeckt werden können sich
pflanzen je nach wetter im april schon
die tomaten ins gewächshaus das
natürlich sehr sehr aufregend oder ein
großer moment das steht also jetzt auch
an wird außerdem wollen auch ganz viele
andere geben wie sehr es entweder im
haus ausgesät werden oder ins beet oder
im spät raus gepflanzt werden und welche
das sind das verrate ich euch in diesem
video da drüben und ansonsten geht raus
und nach die welt ein bisschen grüner
und wir sehen uns nächsten samstag um 10
wieder für ein neues video chats macht's
gut